you're a talented rapper thanks man even
tom green man
yeah me and tom green we recorded
something together i don't think we ever
released it though but
but tom's the homie like i've hung out
with him a bunch over the years when he
was doing his like live show
yeah i was on that a few times that was
before youtube right it started before
youtuber i think so yeah yeah i am
yeah i really like his company he's uh
he's he's he's like polarizing like
obviously he's not always like crazy and
in character but you just don't know
what he's gonna say he has like
his takes on stuff are a little bit
shifted but in a good way right yeah he
uh i got i loved the tom green show man
i was such a
fan me too definitely a big inspiration
and i caught him at the right time so
like there's a there's a guy who like
follows both of us
he's been kind of on our twitter feeds
for a while and he just hit me up and
he's like i was in tokyo i go to japan a
lot and he's like yo tom's in town he's
doing stand-up so i hit tom up and he
goes bro i only have like a half a day
free but i definitely want to meet up
it's crazy that we're in tokyo together
so i was doing live streaming i've been
doing like travel like
i don't know if you know what irl
streaming is it's twitch right it's like
twitch but instead of playing games you
have a backpack with a camera and you
stream like travel stuff okay it's a
really niche thing not a lot of people
do it 99.9 of the people are just
playing games or at home
just talking to the camera right but
so
what what is the duration of an average
irl twitch stream honestly if you want
to make money and you want to be big on
twitch like you know we do like six
hours minimum like yeah yeah sometimes
i'd be out in tokyo
killing all my batteries doing like 10
to 12 hour days like so so are you
reading the comments as it's coming in
and like really engaged the whole time
yeah 100 so the setup is really cool
there's a backpack there's four mobile
routers then i have a selfie stick with
like a wide-angle sony camera and then
under it i have a clamp with a big phone
on it and the phone is segmented into
two pieces the right half is all chat
room and the left half is all alerts
when people subscribe to you and they
donate to you
wow so uh
so i was like yo tom i was like i'm
doing the stream like people would love
to see you if you want to just meet up
for lunch just me and you that's totally
cool but if you want to be on the stream
let me know and i'll bring it and we'll
have some fun and he goes yeah bring it
bring it course he did and uh he killed
it there's so many like viral clips from
that from him
we were walking around
and i just was like you know we went to
get sushi we did have we did
we did a karaoke stream and he was
singing like material girls he's like i
am ah material girl
[ __ ] really funny [ __ ] there's a bit
about like there was like this
trendy ass table with a zipper in the
middle and he just goes to this couple
he goes
that's like a zipper like you zip your
pants
it's like you zip your pants
it's like you zip the zipper like on you
on your pants and he just carried on
where the way he does yeah um well yeah
that was really [ __ ] legendary i'm so
happy i get to hang out with tokyo why
do you always go to japan first of all i
just love japan it's so [ __ ] fun i
feel like if you could go one place
where you take off in a plane and land
somewhere where it feels like you're on
a different planet i feel like it's it's
tokyo you know i love tokyo yeah and it
just
it's like
to me it's like new york city
inside of a lucid dream but clean and
organized think about how boring a lot
of cities are it's like restaurant bar
restaurant bar store restaurant bar
tokyo is so [ __ ] weird bro i love it
it's just so strange you're like oh a
maid cafe some octopus thing themed
cupcake store like it's it's just so
weird it feels like a weird dream and i
just have so much fun walking around
it's really safe like i don't know i
love tokyo you do like super long trips
there you go yeah i go there for like a
month minimum wow wow yeah but also
because i'm there to live stream because
it's like a fun place to stream so i'm
like
it's like definitely fun but it's like a
work fun thing too if i was going there
just to relax and chill
i'd maybe do like two weeks but since
i'm like kind of working and making
money while i'm there i'll stay for a
long time you know yeah do you have uh
like relationships that you've developed
with people who are like die hard glued
to your twitch stream
yes
um a lot of them i don't but some of
them like the way they handle it if they
just show up while i'm like out and
they're just like kind of like
they're weird about it then maybe not
but if i like their personality and i
think they're cool like i'm not gonna
let just them
me meeting them because they were like a
fan or whatever get in the way of that
you know some people are cool about it
they're like hey i know you're i know
where you are i'm in tokyo is it cool if
i stop by for a drink and i'm like yeah
[ __ ] it they'll come by get a drink and
then like no if i like the person that's
that's enough for me you know i mean
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]